we're not quite at the finish line but
these local elections are looking very
good for labor make no mistake this
means that we are on course for a labor
majority of the next election a very
very good set of results for us secure
stomach was speaking as councils across
England were subsumed by a red wave the
Tories have lost seats in their hundreds
not that you'll find Rishi sunak
agreeing with the labor leader look I'm
not detecting any massive Groundswell of
movement towards a labor party or
excitement for their agenda what people
want us to do is focus on their
priorities and one of the redempts well
it seems they too have been winning Here
There and Everywhere liberal Democrats
making big gains across the country
we've beaten the conservatives in bath
and in Brentwood in Hertfordshire and in
Hinckley there's a way to go yet
learned so I knew Paterson and this is
the Sky News deal
and all of that means we are of course
back in the Westminster Studio where
fueled by a combination of sweeties and
caffeine I'm joined by our Deputy
political editor Sam coats also by
Hannah bunting um Sky's election results
analyst lovely to see you both Andrew
awake which is which is very good just
about you you seem to be grimacing there
sounds like I never sleep I keep going
the news the news never sleeps as
someone probably famously said uh Hannah
you look well you look a lot better than
Sam does have you managed to grab any
sleep I've got about an hour and a half
but as long as I just stand up keep
going don't sit down I'm doing okay see
I remember the days when we just crack
on through without having sleep these
two I mean honestly it's ridiculous
anyway let's carry on um I want to start
because we're recording this just around
three o'clock on on Friday afternoon and
handily enough guys in a couple of
minutes just before we came into the
studio I received an email from Greg
hands the conservative party chairman
and I think it's probably a good place
to start it reads this at Neil I always
find it really strange when politicians
address me just put my first name at
Neil I know the results are
disappointing I know people are worried
about what labor councils will mean for
their local communities but I want to be
totally honest with you Neil these local
elections are a massive wake-up call um
I mean Sam he's not wrong
now given it's three o'clock we're
actually about halfway through this
process we've had 105 cancels but
they're 125 of the 230 still left to go
um and many of the councils that are all
out with lots of seats uh are still to
declare which means that at the moment
one of those figures that we're looking
for has the conservative net loss on
minus 300 but there's lots of capacity
for that to grow we'll see whether it
gets to or even possibly Beyond a
thousand but I think Neil the story of
today is at this point now clear so
short of some huge surprise I I think we
know the headlines and so let's explain
why Greg hands is right to be saying
what he's saying
um just to break it down
biggest thing I think that you can say
after looking at the first how many
hours of you know the first 13 hours of
results
is that on the basis of what it's what
we've seen it is so hard
so hard to imagine a conservative
walking into Downing Street after the
next general election if the result is
anything like this the change in chair
of the vote the place some of the places
in which labor are making advances mean
that it is incredibly difficult for the
conservatives uh to form the next
government so that's headline number one
headline number two is a butt labor are
doing well they are doing well all
around the country lots of different
parts of the country
um whether it's uh Medway in Kent
whether it's uh Plymouth and Portsmouth
whether it's uh up further north with
Stoke on Trent the red wall Jonathan
gullis is going to see he's a 2019.01
for the first time off the back of but
all of those ended up going uh to Labor
uh some of them uh like Medway and Kent
have gone all the way from the
conservatives to labor but it doesn't
look quite enough to be able to achieve
that extraordinary feat that kirst
dominates to achieve if he's going to
get an overall majority Hannah just
explain a little bit of the math behind
that because of course part of the
reason that labor have an Almighty
mountain to climb come the next general
election we'll dig down into the
individual results in just a second but
for the big picture stuff part of the
reason that they have this massive
amounting to claim is because they did
pretty badly back in in 2019. so on the
basis of what we have seen so far are we
within the predictions that you and
Michael Thrasher another of course of
scan News election results analysts are
only within the predictions that you
guys have been making
yeah so labor need 124 parliamentary
seats to hit that magic 326 number which
means that they are uh you know at the
slimmest possible majority now that kind
of uh again has only ever happened three
times before for them so once in 1929 a
long time ago once in 1945 and then 1997
labor Landslide um it's a huge gap that
they have got to uh leap over basically
um so what we're seeing at the moment
from this phone where we've done a
national estimated boat share and we're
having the conservatives on roughly 28
to 30 percent and labor roughly on 36 to
38 so there's about a six point
difference between them what labor needs
to get that 124 seats is double that you
know they need a 12 point swing
um whereas they're only showing sort of
a six point different between the two at
the moment so it looks like they would
be the largest party in government but
nowhere close to having a majority and
that has prompted one of the most
interesting most unusual most creative
arguments of the night which is the
labor party saying and this is a bit
reasonable but a bit unreasonable that
if you take into account something that
hasn't happened and we don't know for
sure will happen then we'll get an
overall majority in other words the line
from labor HQ is yes these results are
good enough to give us an overall
majority because we think there's going
to be a collapse of the SMP in Scotland
and labor is going to be the main
beneficiary and there's no doubt by the
way that the polls are going in Labor's
favor in Scotland yeah collapse is a bit
but but a we don't know what's going to
happen with the SMP is a long way to go
two we don't know that labor is going to
be the main beneficiary and three we
don't know on what scale because quite a
lot of those SM NPCs I have quite big
majority so there's a great big bit of
watery about the labor response that
means that they are claiming Victory but
others are saying well we only know what
we know from the numbers and they aren't
that isn't quite as good as you might
have thought okay so Hannah looking just
a little bit more deeply into into what
has been going on and as we said still
an awful long way to go I mean two
things strike me one do we have any idea
as to where the the labor gains have
been made in the main has it just been a
straight conservative to labor swap
because you know the lib Dems have been
growing an awful lot at the moment but
but also that that line from Greg hands
couple of weeks back where he suggested
you know what on track to lose a
thousand seats I I understood that to be
expectation management at the time but
it's looking a possibility at you know
ten past three on Friday afternoon
absolutely yeah Michael Thrasher said
that if the conservatives lost 200 seats
by breakfast then they were on track for
that a thousand loss and that's exactly
what we saw happen
um across the country it looks like
there is definitely some direct labor
gain from the conservatives and the same
for Liberal Democrat gain from the
conservatives but that independent and
other vote share is really interesting
to watch as well because that was very
high in 2019 which is the results that
we're comparing this to
um and also some of these councils were
really precarious the conservatives
could have lost uh half of their
councils by losing only five or fewer
seats
um so the churn has been huge and that
precarity is turning into a lot of these
changing hands and just on on the lib
Dems I mean again kind of back of a fact
packet calculation and the the scantist
of analysis by me but you look at where
they've been picking up I mean if I were
to If I Were a conservative MP with a
bit of a marginal constituency sitting
in the blue wall right now I would be
breaking it absolutely and that is
another thing that means that labor
can't really become the largest party uh
you know and have a majority because
everyone of those seats that the liberal
Democrats take is a seat that the labor
party cannot take from the conservatives
you know so mathematically it turns into
yes the conservatives are falling uh the
liberal Democrats and labor are gaining
but that means that labor can't hit that
magic 326 number if we saw the same
thing happen at the Parliamentary level
Sam remind me the last time we talked
talked about local elections you told me
there were three things that we needed
to keep an eye out for remind our
listeners oh hurray you remember I
didn't remember the three things that's
what I'm asking you to remind me you
listen you noticed something I said
which is better than normal right there
are three ways in which you can judge a
local election the first is the number
of seats that change hands currently the
conservatives are down 292 labor are up
163. the second way that you can judge
the way that uh local elections are
going up by the way that the number of
councils change Hands So currently
overall the conservative it has have
lost 21 councils that's because as
Hannah said actually it's really easy if
they just leaves a tiny number for a lot
of conservative councils to no longer be
uh in charge in it to go to no overall
control uh the labor party have picked
up six councils the third way that you
measure local election performance is by
the share of the vote and that is
uh the thing that is still being
calculated but for the first time ever
on a Friday we haven't had this before
it's a really big great Innovation huge
kudos to Michael Thrasher Hannah and all
of the team we do have uh rough
percentages they're the ones that Hannah
was just outlining uh 28 to 30 for the
tour reads 36 to 38 for labor 18 to 20
uh for lib Downs that's very high uh 16
to 19 uh for other
um and
um and and I think you have to put all
of it together and I think
one of the things that's that's
interesting is that yes labor have been
doing well in some of the areas that
they need to do and there's a huge
geographical spread of areas where
they've Advanced but there's also areas
where they're plateauing a bit and and I
think in the wash-up of this set of
local elections that labor will be
having next week
they'll be wondering I think in
particular in bits of the Midlands why
they didn't end up uh going uh do better
than they have done sort of this is the
walsalls and uh uh and places like that
I think have underperformed uh when it
came to expectations so they're big big
big victories that have been that were
that were signaled in advance places
like Swindon places like Plymouth uh uh
and um and Stoke funny enough we had
cameras at most of those
um because some people know what they're
doing
um but um I I think in some of the areas
where they're less Keen to talk about
and and can I just I just want because
I'm obsessed by uh the spin that goes on
around local elections
the labor party have this argument he's
brilliant it's brilliant it goes the
only thing that matters is the areas
that matter in a general election and
let me tell you Neil let me tell you
we're doing really well in those right
when you hear that what you need to
realize is that is them going so what
we're going to do is we're only going to
tell you about some results but not
others and we're certainly not going to
tell you about all results and so every
time they say what matters is that um is
that we're doing well in the areas where
we need to in a general election they
are cherry picking the bits the argument
that make it work reject delete all
those bits because they're meaningless
to be fair I was just about to ask you
on the basis of your three tests seats
councils and you know watching and swing
which party has been responsible for the
most egregious spend today I mean I was
going to throw Greg Greg hands hat into
the ring for a saying I know people are
worried about what labor councils will
mean for the local communities yeah
especially those local communities that
it just voted them in by the hundreds of
thousands I mean terrified as they
marked the X on the ballot paper Neil
exactly so so but are you perhaps
suggesting that actually you know for
all of up for all of the chat you know
labor might be uh the worst it's been
today I mean they've had a good day they
are entitled to take a little bit of
spend
um yes and and I and I think that's true
and I think that's logical because in a
sense the conservatives went into the
set of local elections knowing that they
had the least to lose in spin terms
because they have the most to lose in
terms of seats and vote sharing councils
so there wasn't much point in
sugarcating it and then and then and
then being embarrassed and although it's
just gone three o'clock and we aren't
you know halfway in terms of counting of
councils it is internally possible that
we we do end up somewhere near that
magical terrible thousand figure uh that
has seen Michael Thrasher's reputation
introduced as the tour he's used as a
central prediction when in fact all
Michael was saying is that's the very
very very very very worst case scenario
well that very very very very well worst
case scenario looks like it might end up
becoming something approximating what
really happened that doesn't mean it's
okay it still means it's very very very
very very terrible so in a sense they're
less guilty of the crime of spin whereas
labor labor have been saying you know in
our analysis we've done they were saying
last Friday to me this is how we'll spin
you on Friday morning and lo and behold
they've done it and and they're doing it
honest and it's working with some people
but it's not working in the studio talk
to me about about the liberal Democrats
I mean if you were watching as I was
indeed David with the sound down this
morning you might have been a little bit
gobsmacked by yet another lib Dem
campaign stunt that time's up for
parishi cringe cringe cringe but if
you're watching with the sound sound off
I mean you'd have thought you'd have won
the lottery I mean is he right to be as
happy and and is this the beginning of
the return of the liberal Democrats as a
force in National politics yeah I think
uh at the Tiverton and Honiton
collection it was a wall that they
smashed through or something they always
seemed to have these sort of big
spectacular uh displays when they when
they're doing well I mean that National
estimated vote share projection of 18 to
20 if they hit the top of that the
liberal Democrats haven't had a 20 share
um Charlie Charlie Kennedy well yeah and
you know as far back as I've been
looking which is about 20 years they
haven't had that they reached 19 I think
it was uh in 2018 uh sometime around
then so it is a very very good night for
them if they are able to do that can I
ask a question
um
don't take this wrong way I was
surprised how high the liberal Democrat
figure was
um uh is it is the liberal Democrat vote
what we say in the jargon being used
efficiently is it in the places that
they need it to be and is it delivering
them seats and would it deliver them
seats at a general election or are there
lots of kind of Wells of liberal
Democrat votes from what we can see that
are building up in places that are of no
good to them so it's still unclear
whether or not they're back in as a
force in elections in the way they were
until Nick Legend well because of our
voting system it's easier to get that
concentration of votes in a ward than it
is in a parliamentary constituency so
although they do have this sort of
concentrated support that we're seeing
translated into seats and it is where
they are challenge challenges to the
conservatives and where they could
really do some damage to the
conservatives how that would aggregate
up to parliamentary constituency is
something that you know remains to be
seen and also we're going to have
boundary changes that come into force on
the first of July but let's talk then
about what we can take from the set of
the results again we keep saying this
we're recording this around three
o'clock but you know there is a fair way
to go but we have a very good idea of
the direction of travel
given that there are no seats being
contested outside of England given that
even within England you're missing out
London and several the other big
metropolitan areas 8 000 Council seats I
think there are there are their advice
how much can we truly learn about what
is going to happen at the next general
election from from this set of data
you you asked me that question last time
we were in the studio Neil am I going to
give you the same answer or you could
just splice in the Lancer from last time
if you want because clearly this is one
of those questions you weren't listening
to the answer for yep but you have to
treat it gently but the uh if you look
at the graphs of seats or share
um the local elections results give you
an indication they give you a flavor of
the direction of British politics
inevitably on days like today People
Like Us get out the slide rule and
calculate it to the nth degree but it is
the case that you know a few years
before there's been a change of
um prime minister a party and prime
minister you know the the party with the
largest number of seats changes so that
happened I think it was 1991 ahead of
1997 2002 or three ahead of 2010 you
know there's a there's a relationship
there
um but it's not the closest and most
intimate relationship
um but neither is it um of no material
fact and the reason for that is yes
there are local issues that don't don't
prefigure nationally but also a lot of
people don't pay any attention to those
local issues and only vote on them what
little I mean it's amazing to me that
they don't spend all all their day
listening to you and me but but
incredibly some of them don't uh and
that um they just rely on whatever
little they know about the political
party so it's a bit National it's a bit
local that's all that's all quite
understandable and in some places it's
more local in some places they haven't
heard of any of the councils or anything
that's happening so it's it's a bit more
kind of default to what they've heard
about National
and we've been talking for you know best
part of a year now at least about how
far labor ahead uh in the polls you know
with some seat projections of getting
them you know over 400 seats at a
parliamentary election
but that's based on opinion polling
right which is it's super valuable and
it gives a really good temperature of of
what the public are thinking about and
especially the governing party and an
opposition party but that is different
to an actual election campaign and when
people have to walk into a voting booth
and put an X next to somebody's name and
a party's name so what we can take from
this is okay well our labor performing
as well at The Ballot Box as they are in
the opinion polls
um and it looks like from you know
around 70 of people in England were
eligible to vote in these elections and
it looks like they are on course to be
that largest party but not to gain that
majority
so I'm just just towards on the kind of
the pure politics of all of this I've
been listening quite closely to to the
to the the spinning being put out there
by the conservatives today and Rishi
sunak has as you would expect as all
Party leaders do at times like this has
been front and center and said I've been
listening we understand uh we understand
that people are voting this way for for
for whatever reason but can he escape
blame
for this disastrous set of results you
know the the line would be you know he
has been in job for you know a handful
of months look at the people that came
before him Liz truss Boris Johnson
that's an awful weight to have around
your neck when you head into an election
I mean can he spin it in that fashion
that this is not all down to him because
you know the whole point of sunac was to
steady the ship was to stop the road and
he hasn't
um I think the answer is let's see where
the conversation goes from from here on
in now uh I saw Rishi sanak earlier
today
um and uh for one of those pool
interviews and that's where we you
basically do an interview for all the
broadcasters that's right and um however
hard I tried the Rishi bot gave the same
answer to every question you're gonna be
welcome in number 10 if you keep going
like this nobody likes me I don't care
um and essentially his answer was I
under with his with his best sad face I
you know I'm very disappointed for any
conservative that loses their seat uh
but the bottom line is
um uh we're gonna work really hard the
people's priorities and my five
priorities um did you know that I want
to stop the small boats
um and he said that three times and then
we moved on to the coronation
um and that's his line right I'm
steadying the ship and I've got a plan
to do it and my plan is the best plan
but
there was a really interesting voice
that voice actually was speaking to John
Craig overnight the outgoing leader the
ex-conservative leader of Medway Council
who put the blame firmly at the national
party and frankly pretty pretty close to
Rishi soon next door he was saying look
I think that there's no answer for us
with the cost of living crisis when it
comes up on the doorstep um uh I think
we've got problems with the planning
system now I think by that they mean
they think the planning system allows
for building too many houses actually
British unax one of the British
elections first decisions was to relax
the plans that they were going to have
caving into his back benches so it's so
the cave-in is not enough I think is it
was implicitly the message uh from the
uh from from the Medway outgoing Tory
leader and and that there's still too
much noise from the Parliamentary party
now richardsonette would hope that over
time that noise diminishes and some of
these um but but I don't I don't see
that there's an answer to cost of living
and planning uh anytime soon so
you know that there is going to be some
some some blame attached there's no way
that it isn't and even though he's in a
much politically stronger position I
think it opens up a new conversation I
don't think that conversation
substantially is the one that John
Redwood wants to have which is please
can you slash taxes and roll back the
state which is what he's kind of already
taken to Twitter to say uh it being um a
weekday and um but I do think that if um
the defeated candidates the MPS
representing areas that went
substantially backwards think that there
is big big political problem there then
I think that Daniel may be forced to
sort of rethink a bit and just seriously
just a thing a word from you Hannah
um no Sam knows this already I am not a
man who is Riven by Vice but
occasionally I have done a better
political betting I just wonder as it
came over for Rishi sunak is there any
chance that at the next general election
uh the conservatives will be the
majority party well I mean I don't like
to say that anything is impossible right
because we've been surprised so many
some times over the last five ten years
however many it's been that all of this
has been going on
um but it's it's amounting to climb
right he has had enough time to study
the ship or to prove integrity and
competence and all of the things that he
said that he was coming to do
um but that hasn't translated into a
good local election result if I could
put Hannah's thoughts in my language it
could turn out that kirstan was a
martian could turn out that Rishi sudak
has superpowers it might turn out that
Ed Davey is the next Messiah Neil we
just don't know thank goodness and Sam I
will let you crack on much more work for
you today but for no thanks my thanks to
Hannah to Sam and of course to you for
listening to the Sky News Daily with me
Neil Patterson this Edition was produced
by Emery Woodhouse our editor is Philly
borant